das hier sind die Vertreter von 13
mächtigen Firmen unter anderem BMW Shell
und total wie jedes Jahr treffen sie
sich auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum in
Davos 2017 entsteht hier der hydrogen
Council eine wasserstofflobbygruppe die
dafür sorgt dass das fossile Geschäft
der Öl und Gaskonzerne länger am Leben
bleibt und das unter anderem durch
Wasserstoffautos wait what
Wasserstoffautos sind doch eigentlich
eine super Lösung wasserstoff ist das
häufigste Element im Universum und er
kann quasi überall klimaneutral
hergestellt werden Wasserstoffautos sind
in ein paar Minuten betankt haben eine
Reichweite die man sonst nur vom
Verbrenner kennt und stoßen beim Fahren
ausschließlich sauberen Wasserdampf aus
aber was wenn ich dir sage dass diese
wasserstofflobby jährlich allein in der
EU über 75 Millionen Euro ausgibt damit
wir all das glauben dass ist neben dem
hydrogen Council noch zahlreiche andere
Allianzen von Big Oil autoher stellern
und der Chemiebranche gibt die
Wasserstoff green Wasen und dass es
einen großen Haken gibt wenn wir überall
auf Wasserstoff setzen wie
umweltfreundlich ist das Wasserstoffauto
wirklich und was haben Shell BP und Co
davon wenn du daran glaubst genau darum
geht es jetzt in diesem
Video ein Disclaimer zu Beginn
Wasserstoff an sich brauchen wir in
Zukunft auf jeden Fall es gibt mega
viele coole Technologien die darauf
setzen und die super sinnvoll sind aber
in diesem Video fokussieren wir uns auf
den Einsatz von Wasserstoff in Autos und
der ist nicht so sinnvoll okay wovon
reden wir hier eigentlich statt einer
Batterie haben Wasserstoffautos einen
Wasserstofftank und eine Brennstoffzelle
die die chemische Energie des
Wasserstoffs in elektrische Energie für
den Elektromotor umwandelt
Wasserstoffautos sind also auch
E-Autos fürs beschleunigen und die
Rekuperation also die Rückgewinnung von
Energie beim Bremsen besitzen
Wasserstoff auf Autos aber auch noch
einen kleinen Akku weil gasförmiger
Wasserstoff eine geringe Dichte hat muss
man ihn komprimieren für Pkw auf 700 bar
also über 200 mal den Druck eines
Autoreifens dadurch haben
Wasserstoffautos tendenziell eine höhere
Reichweite und können viel schneller
tanken als
batterieelektroautos aber wie viele
Wasserstoffautos habt ihr in den letzten
6 Monaten gesehen hier und da vielleicht
mal eins aber wahrscheinlich nicht
ansatzweise so oft wie Elektroautos und
genau das zeigt sich auch in den
Zulassungszahlen zwischen Januar und
September wurden in Deutschland über 2
Millionen Pkw neu zugelassen davon waren
über 387 000 batterieelektroautos aber
nur
252 waren Wasserstoffautos nee nicht 252
000 sondern 252 insgesamt woran liegt
das ein verbessertes Ladenetz hohe
Ladegeschwindigkeiten und bessere
Akkutechnologie machen den
Reichweitenvorteil von Wasserstoffautos
schon kleiner aber Lobbyisten und
Politiker plädieren oft für
technologieoffenheit damit ist gemeint
dass keiner Technologie ein Vorsprung in
der Förderung gegeben werden soll an und
für sich richtig gute Idee Forschung
soll natürlich Ergebnis offen sein aber
NGOs und Medien kritisieren dass der
Begriff auch genutzt wird um
Technologien wie efuels und Wasserstoff
in der Diskussion zu halten dabei ist
der Kampf zwischen E und Wasserstoff
Autos von Industrieseite eigentlich
schon längst entschieden Gewinner ist
ganz klar die Batterie und nur wenige
Hersteller arbeiten noch an
Wasserstoffautos in Deutschland gibt es
z.B auch nur zwei Serienmodelle mit
Wasserstoffantrieb zu kaufen und der
Trend geht nicht aufwärts sondern
abwärts mehrere Modelle wurden
eingestellt durch die niedrigen
Produktionszahlen sind Wasserstoffautos
auch noch echt teuer in der Anschaffung
dazu kommt dass es in Deutschland je
nach Datenbank zwischen 90 und 100
Wasserstofftankstellen gibt die die sind
sinnvoll verteilt und damit ist
Deutschland im Vergleich zum Ausland
eigentlich ganz gut abgedeckt trotzdem
muss man lange Strecken planen ohne
genug wasserstoffahrzeuge auf den
Straßen lohnen sich Tankstellen halt
auch nicht und ohne Tankstellen kauft
man kein Fahrzeug das alte Henne
eiprblem aber anders als bei Ladepunkten
für batterieelektroautos ist die Zahl
über die letzten Jahre auch nicht
wirklich gewachsen okay aber das alles
ist ja der Individualverkehr im
Lastverkehr hieß es lange dass es kaum
eine Alternative zu Wasserstoff geben
wird mittlerweile gibt es aber auch
schon batteriemodelle die mit einer
Akkuladung 300 bis 600 km schaffen und
somit in den vorgeschriebenen pausenplan
der Trucker hineinpassen experten gehen
davon aus dass Wasserstoff nur auf
langen Strecken mit schlechter
Ladeinfrastruktur eine Rolle spielen
wird denn Batterie LKW sind in der
Anschaffung und im Betrieb deutlich
günstiger und das gilt genauso auch fürs
Auto grüner Wasserstoff der mit Strom
aus erneuerbaren Quellen hergestellt
wird wird ohne Subventionen immer teurer
sein als erneuerbarer Strom direkt und
das liegt einfach an den Grundgesetzen
der Physik beim batterieelektroauto wird
die Batterie mit Strom geladen und der
treibt dann den Elektromotor an dabei
geht Energie verloren z.B beim Laden
oder im Motor insgesamt kommen aber 70
bis 80% der Energie auf der Straße an
beim Wasserstoffauto gibt es auch Strom
und einen Elektromotor aber mehrere
verlustreiche Zwischenschritte
zusätzlich allein bei der
Wasserstoffherstellung per Elektrolyse
gehen etwa 30% der Energie verloren dann
wird der Wasserstoff komprimiert gekühlt
und transportiert also noch mal - 20 bis
25%. und in der Brennstoffzelle haben
wir sogar die größten Verluste rund
45%. mit einem Wasserstoffauto braucht
man also für die gleiche Strecke zwei
bis dreimal so viel Strom wie mit einem
Batterie Elektroauto und das spiegelt
sich auch im Preis wieder 1 kogam
Wasserstoff was für etwa 100 km met
reicht kostet an fast allen Tankstellen
über 15 € und die sind sogar noch stark
subventioniert das ist mehr als für 7 l
Benzin oder für 20 Kilowattstunden
selbst an der schnelladesäule schauen
wir jetzt mal auf die CO2 Bilanz der
wasserstoffmobilität immerhin werden
Wasserstoffautos ja als ökologische
Alternative zum E-Auto dargestellt und
hier hat die Lobby ganze Arbeit
geleistet denn ja Wasserstoffautos mögen
praktisch sein aber sie fallen nicht
einfach vom Himmel genauso wenig wieer
Wasserstoff selbst wegen des hohen
Drucks muss der Tank aufwendig aus
Kohlenstoff faserverstärktem Kunststoff
hergestellt werden zusammen mit der
Brennstoffzelle verursacht das ehrnlich
viel CO2 wie eine mittlere
e-autobatterie wenn das Auto dann
klimaneutral laufen würde wäre es das ja
aber wert nur ist das einfach nicht der
Fall um Wasserstoff herzustellen gibt es
verschiedene Methoden grauer Wasserstoff
entsteht bei der sogenannten
Dampfreformierung aus Erdgas weil viele
Faktoren mit einfließen ergeben sich je
nach Scario also etwas andere Zahlen
laut Umweltbundesamt entstehen aber von
der Erdgasförderung bis zum
wasserstofftransport pro Kilogramm
Wasserstoff etwa 16 kg CO2 äquivalente
die IEA spricht wiederum von bis zu 27
kg im Extrem fallall grüner Wasserstoff
entsteht wenn Wasser mit erneuerbarem
Strom in Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff
gespalten wird das ist die sogenannte
Elektrolyse er ist also potenziell
klimaneutral wenn der Transport
klimaneutral ist und der Strom sonst
nicht genutzt worden wäre grüner Strom
und damit auch grüner wasserstoff ist
die einzige Möglichkeit den steigenden
Bedarf CO2 Arm zu decken aber er ist
auch immer noch sehr rar 2022 wurde nur
etwa 0,1% des Wasserstoffs mittels
Elektrizität hergestellt und grüner
wasserstoff ist ja auch nur ein Teil
davon weil ja nicht aller Strom
erneuerbar ist theoretisch kann grüner
Wasserstoff auch aus Überschussstrom
entstehen der wird allerdings relativ
teuer und auch einfach nicht ausreichend
sein also grünen Wasserstoff importieren
auch das wird nicht leicht denn
Pipelines gibt es noch nicht ausreichend
und der Transport per Schiff oder
Tankwagen ist aufwendig und teuer
außerdem müssen sich auch die
Produktionsländer selbst mit Wasserstoff
und Strom versorgen während viele
Branchen also auf den grünen Wasserstoff
hoffen der in der nächsten Zeit aber
knapp sein wird bringt die Lobby eine
vermeintlich super saubere
Brückentechnologie ins Spiel blauen
wasasserstoff warum der aber gar nicht
so sauber ist das klären wir gleich das
heißt damit wasserstoffmobilität
umweltfreundlich sein kann brauchen wir
Grünen Wasserstoff dafür haben wir aber
noch keine ausreichenden
Produktionskapazitäten er ist schwierig
zu transportieren und wird aufgrund der
Ineffizienz teurer sein als normaler
Strom und vor allem es gibt viele andere
Branchen die auch auf Wasserstoff setzen
deshalb sollte der Wasserstoff vor allem
dort eingesetzt werden wo er besonders
viel CO2 einspart und nicht zu ersetzen
ist ein Beispiel dafür ist die
Stahlindustrie aber eben nicht das Auto
dazu kommt der heute an Tankstellen
verkaufte wasserstoff ist nicht grün
genau deswegen vergleichen wir Benzin
mit grauem Wasserstoff für 100 km
braucht man ungefähr 1 kogm das also 16
kg CO2 Emissionen verursacht für diese
CO2 Menge kann man auch 5 l Benzin
herstellen transportieren und verbrennen
wenn man nur auf das schaut was aus dem
Auspuff kommt sind es sogar fast 7 l
undterm Strich gibt es daher einen
emissionsvorteil für Wasserstoffautos
mit fossilem Wasserstoff okay und was
war das jetzt mit dem blauen Wasserstoff
der ist doch bestimmt super nachhaltig
oder na ja der wird eigentlich genauso
gewonnen wie grauer mit dem Unterschied
dass bei der Dampfreformierung 60 bis
90% des CO2 abgeschieden und
unterirdisch gespeichert werden das
klingt zwar richtig schlau und super
umweltfreundlich und es wird auch so
vermarktet aber die Emissionen entstehen
eben nicht nur bei der Dampfreformierung
an sich sondern auch beim er
gasttransport oder durch den
Energieaufwand bei der Herstellung
dadurch verursacht 1 kgam blauer
Wasserstoff trotzdem noch 12 bis 13 kg
CO2 äquivalente und ist damit kaum
weniger schädlich als grauer und ein
Teil der Emissionen wird durch Methan
verursacht das auf kurze Zeit gesehen
sogar noch deutlich klimaschädlicher ist
als CO2 blauer Wasserstoff ein sehr
spannendes Thema über das wir eigentlich
mal ein ganz eigenes Video machen
könnten wenn Lobbyorganisationen grau
Wasserstoff greenwashen und für blauen
Wasserstoff lobbiieren dann ist das
nicht aus Umweltbewusstsein wenn sie
damit Erfolg haben und sich Wasserstoff
im Individualverkehr durchsetzen sollte
dann sind wir für sehr lange Zeit
abhängig von fossilen Rohstoffen und
wenn das nicht klappt hat die Lobby
zumindest Verwirrung gestiftet und die
Elektrifizierung verzögert und ich würde
sogar behaupten dass das ihr primäres
Ziel ist weil sie nämlich ganz genau
wissen dass Wasserstoff im
Individualverkehr keinen Sinn ergibt die
IEA das W Institut der nationale
wasserstoffrat experten sehen
Wasserstoffautos nicht in großen Mengen
auf den Straßen übrigens wie immer bei
unseren Videos Quellen zu allen unseren
Aussagen findet ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung es gibt einfach viele
andere Einsatzbereiche von Wasserstoff
in denen er wirklich unverzichtbar ist
wo er einen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz
leistet statt Klimaschutz zu verhindern
trotzdem sagen viele sie warten aufs
Wasserstoffauto und holen sich deshalb
kein E-Auto aber erstens müss man dann
schon lange nicht mehr warten sondern
könn sich längst eins kaufen wenn man es
denn ernst meint und zweitens ist das
eine Entscheidung die nicht
umweltfreundlicher oder günstiger sein
wird als ein batterieelektroauto oder
noch viel besser gar kein Auto zu kaufen
wer eAutos schlecht macht und für
technologieoffenheit pläert unterstützt
also bewusst oder unbewusst die Öl und
gaslobby dabei ihr altes Geschäftsmodell
länger am Leben zu erhalten wie gerade
gesagt das beste Auto ist gar kein Auto
und wenn ihr denkt das geht bei mir
nicht der Supermarkt ist viel zu weit
weg oder ihr vielleicht auch einfach
eure Autofahrten reduzieren wollt dann
hilft euch hello fresh hello fresh
liefert nämlich eure Zutaten fürs Kochen
einfach nach Hause anstatt dass viele
Leute jeweils einzeln mit ihrem
tonnenschweren Auto zum Supermarkt
fahren fährt also ein meist elektrischer
Lieferwagen von hellof frresh ganz viele
Wohnungen ab und stellt euch das Essen
direkt vor eure Tür und das sogar direkt
in den richtigen Mengen ich muss mir
also nicht für ein einzelnes Gericht
Zutaten kaufen von den ich dann am Ende
vielleicht wieder irgendwas wegschmeißen
muss weil es übrig bleibt für uns bei dr
Watson hat kochen und gemeinsames Essen
tatsächlich einen besonderen Stellenwert
wir bekochen uns abwechselnd in unseren
Mittagspausen und versuchen uns immer
gegenseitig mit neuen Ideen zu
überraschen bei HelloFresh kann man ganz
einfach mit der App aus einem breiten
Angebot wählen und man muss sich dank
der mitgelieferten Rezepte keine
Gedanken über die Zubereitung machen und
damit bleibt dann mehr Zeit zum Kochen
und vor allem essen wenn ihr hell frresh
auch einmal ausprobieren wollt dann
benutzt gerne unseren Code hello dr
Watson und gönnt euch ganze 120 €
Neukundenrabatt und außerdem spart euch
auch noch die Versandtkosten auf die
erste Box den Link zu hellesh findet ihr
unten in der Videobeschreibung oder hier
mit dem QRCode in diesem Sinne bleibt
neugierig euer CC